[Musique]
et aujourd'hui j'accueille amélie de
montchalin secrétaire d'état aux
affaires européennes bonjour amélie
montchanin jours alors nous sommes
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview
en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté
aujourd'hui par sébastien couratin du
journal l'écho républicain bonjour
sébastien couratin bonjour alexandre
tout ça je rappelle que votre journal
l'écho républicain couvre l'actualité du
département de l'eure et loire et de la
région centre
exactement alors on va commencer par la
situation internationale et les
manifestations qui s'intensifie aux
états unis après la mort de l'afro
américain george floyd lors d'une
intervention policière le président
américain donald trump a évoqué hier le
recours à l'armée il appelle à l'armée
est ce que cette situation dans l'une
des plus grande démocratie au monde vous
inquiète
d'abord c'est la mort de george clooney
est une vraie tragédie est donc
effectivement on est très préoccupé on
est en particulier très préoccupée par
tout les violences que l'on voit
aujourd'hui à l'oeuvre et on voit bien
qu'il est nécessaire aujourd'hui de tout
faire pour qu'il y ait de l'apaisement
pour qu'il y ait de la justice et que
cette grande démocratie puisse
effectivement retrouvé secours d'un
fonctionnement apaisé et justement est
ce que vous trouvez que donald trump
réalise et bien de l'apaisement dans
cette situation avec ses tweets
multiples je vais pas commenter ici vous
voyez les déclarations des uns et des
autres je pense que vraiment une
démocratie comme celle des états unis
doit pouvoir retrouver avec l'action de
tous de l'apaisement de la justice et au
fond régler les questions profondes qui
se manifeste par des violences
aujourd'hui je crois que c'est plus par
l'action par le dialogue qu'on peut
traverser une telle période qui est une
vraie à nouveau tragédie humaine et on
voit qu'ils posent beaucoup de questions
sociales mais au delà des déclarations
le recours à l'armée pour contrôler des
manifestations cela pose problème pour
une démocratie comme les états unis
sur ce la clé c'est stopper les
violences et réouvrir une période
d'apaisement de dialogue de justice je
crois que les etats-unis en ont besoin
le monde entier et accompagnera ce
mouvement ça c'est possible avec donald
trump
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il vaut mieux se
focaliser sur ce qui se passe plutôt que
de faire la politique fiction alors on
va parler du déconfinement puisque nous
sommes au premier jour de cette phase 2
déconfinement avec des français plus
libéré leurs déplacements ne vont plus
être limité
et d'ailleurs on a appris ce week-end
que dans deux semaines eh bien les
places dans les trains pourront tous
être occupé il n'y aura plus la règle du
un siège sur deux est ce qu'on ne va pas
trop vite dans ce déconfinement déjà je
pense qu'il faut remercier les français
qui ont fait bon part de beaucoup de
civisme beaucoup de responsabilités qui
rendent possible au fond cette ce
déconfinement par étapes de plus en plus
grande
le fait qu'on puisse retrouver
progressivement une vie normale après on
le voit bien la situation sanitaire
reste extrêmement voilà à suivre avec
beaucoup de vigilance il faut que chacun
puisse continuer à appliquer les gestes
barrière il faut qu'on soit tous
extrêmement prudent on a fait face à une
maladie qu'on ne connaissait pas
peut-être qu'on en connaît d'ailleurs
pas toutes les mécanismes toutes les
conséquences donc on doit être vigilant
on essaye de faire les choses par étapes
on essaie d'aller faire avec bon sens
avec beaucoup de responsabilité donc je
crois que ce qui était proposé va dans
cette dynamique mais là aussi il faudra
qu'on reste vigilant on cherche à
permettre aux français de retrouver une
vie la plus normale possible tout en
étant conscient qu'elle sera toujours un
peu différente parce que cette maladie
est toujours là parmi nous et cela passe
condé confirme qu'elle est parti et je
crois qu'il faut qu'on est tous bien ça
en tête sébastien une question sur les
frontières absolument la question de
l'ouverture des frontières entre pays
européens
on s'achemine peut-être vers le 15 juin
ou comment ça se passe on a l'impression
que tous les pays qui jouent pas la même
partition et tire pas dans le même sens
déjà on peut pas avoir une harmonisation
totale sur ce sujet parce que le virus
n'a pas circulé au même moment n'a pas
circulé de manière homogène et donc
c'est normal que y est au fond chacun
est aussi une situation sanitaire à
gérer qu'il soit pas exactement la même
quête toujours pas la même aujourd'hui
entre ce qui se passe en italie en
espagne en france en belgique au royaume
uni on est tous dans des situations
assez différentes
la clé c'est qu'on se coordonnent et que
personne ne prenne des mesures qui
mettent en danger
voyez la progression sanitaire positive
des uns et des autres notre objectif
avec jean yves le drian avec christophe
castaner avec laure nonies et d'assurer
une coordination autour de nous avec nos
pays voisins et sang il ya beaucoup
travaillé pendant les dernières semaines
les derniers mois on s'achemine et on
aimerait pouvoir effectivement suspendre
la plupart la majorité des contrôles
notamment
effectivement avec ses doigts du 15 juin
on reste très vigilant s'il joue au
changement il faut qu'on reste
voilà souple ce qui est clé pour moi
c'est que je vais me rendre voyez
vendredi en allemagne et à la frontière
franco allemande entre amos et la sarre
c'est un lieu d'abord il ya eu beaucoup
de solidarité avec notamment transfert
des patients qui ont été cueillis en
allemagne c'est un lieu où on travaille
aussi beaucoup sur le bassin de vie
frontaliers notamment les travailleurs
puissent passer les frontières que les
familles notamment puissent aller rendre
visite à leurs proches
je pense notamment aux enfants aux
personnes âgées de part et d'autre et
pour qu'effectivement on puisse le plus
rapidement possible coordonner cette
levée des contrôles et qu'on retrouve
une circulation
ça doit se faire avec la coordination
maintenant je vous dis c'est normal
qu'ils aient pas d'harmonisation parce
que le virus ne va pas toujours tous
touchés pareil et puis concernant le
tourisme et notamment les vacances d'été
le gouvernement a beaucoup parlé de
vacances bleu blanc rouge est ce que
vous conseiller aux français d'aller en
vacances en france ou en europe
moi je leur conseille déjà d'être
prudent parce que la situation sanitaire
on l'a dit nous appellent tous à
d'ailleurs prudent être aussi flexible
parce qu'il ya des choses peut-être qui
se passe lorsqu'on pas exactement comme
on le pensait d'ailleurs on a tous été
surpris par ce qui s'est passé le but
sur tourisme et c'est tout le plan qui a
été présenté par jean baptiste lemoyne
avec jean yves le drian et premier
ministre ce à la fois de faire revenir
les français dans des lieux touristiques
en france c'est de permettre à des
européens de venir chez nous c'est
permettre aux français de partir à
l'étranger c'est que tout le monde
puisse passer de bonnes vacances
après effectivement il faut qu'on soit
prudent il faut qu'on soit vigilant et
donc peut-être que certaines
destinations
et bien ne sont pas tout à fait adapté
la situation mais le but c'est quand
même qu'on rende sa possible c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs qu'au niveau européen on a
une stratégie coordonnée des protocoles
sanitaires à appliquer partout en europe
pour que chacun quand il part un peu
plus loin de chez lui mais trouve des
choses qui soient harmonisés et qui me
donne confiance ça les touristes c'est
une part importante de nos économies
c'est aussi une part importante de notre
rayonnement dans notre attractivité est
donc le but c'est que tout ça reparte
mais là aussi avec vigilance et prudence
est justement de la relance économique
on va en parler puisqu'il y a quelques
jours
la commission européenne a présenté son
propre son plan de relance de l'économie
européenne alors je vais le détailler
brièvement il ya 500 milliards d'euros
de subventions aux états membres qui
était d'ailleurs à l'initiative du plan
franco allemand il est également 250
milliards d'euros de prêts et puis ces
fonds vont être intégrés dans un budget
européen de
lens entre 2021 et 2027 qui s'élèvera à
1850 milliards d'euros ça y'est l'europe
est au rendez vous alors il faut
reprendre effectivement les choses par
étapes et comprendre ce qui se joue
aujourd'hui il ya deux en fait
grand enjeu devant nous est d'abord
effectivement un enjeu de rbo de relance
comment on sort de cette crise
économique comment on en sort ensemble
on est extrêmement interdépendants les
uns et des autres ça a fait notre
prospérité faut pas que ça devienne une
fragilité
aujourd'hui nous si en france on
continue et on fait beaucoup d'aider nos
entreprises on peut pas leur inventer
des clients et si ces clients sont en
italie sont en allemagne sont en espagne
en slovaquie où je ne sais où
il faut que leurs clients puissent leur
faire des commandes et donc il faut que
notre économie dans son ensemble reparte
et ce assez
le plan de relance c'est au fond sa
capacité à nous assurer un rebond et 1
rebond qu'ils soient collectives pour
que ce soit un vrai roman parce que si
on fait des rebonds chacun de notre côté
on va rebondir
chacun moins loin que ce qu'on peut
faire ensemble et puis ensuite il y aura
il ya tout un enjeu ensuite
d'investissement qu'est ce qu'on veut
faire en européen pour la décennie qui
vient
comme en face à la chine face aux états
unis on s'affirme comment on protège
leur agriculture notre autonomie
alimentaire comment protège notre
industrie dans le numérique comment on
met dans la voiture électrique par
exemple des moyens
tous ces sujets là c'est pas des sujets
vous voyez sur 18 mois à deux ans c'est
des sujets sur une décennie et donc
c'est là où on a effectivement bâtis une
ambition avec ce budget européen
c'est une négociation difficile que je
mène maintenant déjà depuis pas mal de
temps parce qu'elles étaient déjà lancés
avant la crise elle devient d'autant
plus urgente
parce que c'est un enjeu de souveraineté
il s'impose plus que jamais à nous
l'initiative franco allemande qui a eu
lieu à ce titre c'est probablement l'un
des moments les plus importants du
quinquennat
c'est un moment où la france et
l'allemagne se mettent d'accord non pas
sur le plus petit dénominateur commun
nappe font pas une synthèse voiliers de
leurs différences mais disent voilà
voilà la vision qu'on a pour l'europe
on veut une europe qui soit souveraine
sur la santé on veut une europe qui soit
forte et en leader de la transition
écologique
on veut une industrie européenne depuis
s'affirmer mettons-y les moyens et c'est
comme ça qu'on est arrivé aux cinq sens
bien et aussi à l'idée que ce budget
européen jusqu'en 2027
il devait être absolument ambitieux
cohérent avec la transition numérique la
transition écologique et donc nous
amener vraiment à penser en européen
notre puissance en crédibilité et une
souveraineté pour ça il faut mettre les
nombre d'accords c'est vous qui allez
mener les négociations être être à la
baguette sur ce dossier il ya quatre
pays du nord les fameux frugaux pays bas
autriche suède danemark à convaincre
qu'ils sont pas très chauds sur la
partie subventions comment vous allez
faire mais nous on cherche à avoir un
accord avant début juillet parce que si
on parle de relance c'est pas la peine
d'arriver une fois que les choses seront
finis quand même besoin d'accompagner
cette sortie de crise donc il faut que
les choses aillent vite
il y aura un sommet des chefs d'état de
gouvernement le 18 juin
et effectivement on a quelques pays
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont qui prennent de
la distance qu'il faut en dise oui bah
si les pays ont besoin on a qu'a donnée
à cela seulement
je prends un exemple la suède la suisse
est un pays vous savez qu'il n'a pas
mené de même confinement que d'autres
pays qui néanmoins malgré ça va avoir
une chute de pib de 7 8% ou peut-être
même plus parce que c'est un pic
extrêmement exportateurs et donc si les
suédois rend heureux consommées ont vécu
un hiver peut-être plus normalement peut
être que ce que nous qui avons connu un
confinement plus plus ferme plus
strictes ils ont toujours pas de clients
et donc ce que je dis la semaine c'est
ne nous lançons pas dans des débats
théoriques ne nous payons pas le luxe de
prendre du temps sur des débats qui sont
objectivement d'une autre époque
regardons les faits les faits c'est que
vous tout seul suédois
vous aurez beau inonder votre économie
d'argent si les pays dans lesquels vos
entreprises exportent ne repartent pas
votre économie ne repartira pas non plus
et donc je crois que cette idée qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas chacun une île et
il ya des pays effectivement qu'on des
moyens mais leurs moyens seul c'est
formidable pour eux mais ça ne permettra
pas de repartir si leurs voisins ne se
porte pas mieux et c'est cette vision
notre interdépendance qui aujourd'hui
fait que vous avez des pays qui évolue
et donc vous avez l'autriche le danemark
la finlande les pays bas qui aujourd'hui
quand même voit bien que à eux seuls ils
ne peuvent pas sortir l'allemagne a fait
ce chemin
l'allemagne a une grande puissance
financière pourquoi il propose de mettre
500 milliards de subventions sur la
table parce qu'elle voit bien que
l'économie dans son pays ne repartira
pas si l'italie ne repart pas si
l'espagne ne repart pas si les pays plus
à l'est de l'allemagne ne repartent pas
non plus et ils ont été très durement
touchée par les conséquences de la crise
sanitaire qu'on vient de connaître
et justement dans la négociation sur ces
500 milliards de subventions est-ce que
la france peut faire des concessions et
diminuer le montant de ses subventions
alors est-ce que la france reste un
transit intransigeante mais nous on
n'est pas là on n'avait pas à faire des
concessions voyez bien on va pas la
souveraineté européenne on va pas le
faire à 80% on le fait on ne fait pas
donc si je vous dis on veut un plan dans
l'aéronautique en vain plan pour
l'électrification de l'automobile on
veut un plan pour la transition
énergétique
il faut le faire vraiment si on se dit
voilà on va regarder les besoins par
exemple d'incident comme le tourisme on
vient d'en parler il faut y mettre les
moyens
et donc aujourd'hui on n'est pas voyez
dans l'ajustement déjà des chiffres on
est déjà se poser le principe selon
lequel on est tous bien d'accord que on
ne peut s'en sortir qu'ensemble et que
s'en sortir ensemble ça veut dire mettre
des moyens qu'ils soient vraiment
partager la grande révolution si je peux
parler comme ça c'est que nous rentrons
dans un débat différentes ce qui était
jusqu'à maintenant le cas au niveau
européen qui était cette logique de du
juste retour je mets tant d'euros sur la
table parce que je veux retrouver
exactement les mêmes montants c'est le
fameux iphone my money back de même de
margaret thatcher
ça a beaucoup beaucoup abîmé la logique
européenne parce que dans ce marché
intérieur il ya des choses dont on
bénéficie qui sont pas exactement lié à
combien on met chacun sur la table c'est
notre dynamique collective et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui on cette crise a nous a
montré à combien on est est
interdépendant et donc combien on devait
mettre ensemble pour repartir réellement
économiquement socialement et préparer
l'avenir
alors cette relance passe par un budget
européen plutôt ambitieux entre 2021 et
emmanuel macron veut créer une europe de
la santé souveraine sur le plan
sanitaire concrètement à quoi elle va
ressembler il ya trois étapes
il ya d'abord la capacité à faire de la
veille à être réactif à suivre les
épidémies et on voit bien que cette
capacité d'anticipation
si on avait pu la voir tous un peu plus
au niveau européen je pense qu'on aurait
tous été dans de meilleures conditions
donc sa première capacité ensuite il est
question de réduire indépendance à
l'extérieur sur des produits essentiels
certains médicaments
on apprend notamment beaucoup parlé des
médicaments de réanimation les
équipements de protection les masques on
pense qu'on a besoin de soutenir la
relance
une vraie économie de production de ces
biens en europe pour pouvoir en avoir
sur notre continent pour les exporter
d'ailleurs mais avoir les capacités
chez nous et puis il ya une 3 un
troisième volet est un volet de
recherche aux êtres voilà un continent
qui sur les vaccins sur le cancer sur
toutes les maladies de vieillissement
eh bien tu un continent qui revient j'ai
à dire est déjà très avancé mais devient
un vrai leader qui peut aussi proposer
des solutions
c'est quand on dit que le vaccin on
aimerait en faire un bien public mondial
contre-courant d'un virus c'est d'autant
plus facile à faire que vous avez chez
vous la recherche vous avez chez vous
les moyens d'offrir ensuite ce genre de
choses à des pays qui sont moins moins
favorisés
l'autre enjeu de ce budget c'est la
relance verte concrètement comment ça
peut se mettre en place
ça se met en place dans tous les
secteurs oui l'écologie c'est plus ni
l'apanage d'un parti et c'est plus un
secteur en soit il faut qu'on réforme
comment on produit notre alimentation
comment se déplacent comment notre
industrie fonctionne il faut qu'on
réfléchisse aussi à nos importations
c'est pour ça que le président la
république et on a fait beaucoup de
progrès mais font ce qu'on appelle un
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières une taxe carbone aux
frontières
on peut pas nous mettre des normes
extrêmement dure mais souhaitable sur un
an ce nombre de secteurs et puis
continuer à importer des produits pour
lesquels on ferait pas la différence du
co2 émis a justement c'est probable
qu'il y ait une taxe carbone aux
frontières c'est dans le plan de la
commission
beaucoup de pays nous ont rejoins c'est
d'ailleurs un sujet sur lequel dans les
derniers mois on a fait énormément
d'avancé parce qu'on voit bien qu'ils
aient une forme de lucidité ce fait que
l'écologie c'est pas un sujet juste de
discours il faut maintenant que ça
rentre dans tous les domaines économique
et donc ce plan de relance on joue pas
ce budget européen
il a au moins 25% qui strictement dédiés
au climat mais l'intégralité ces
dépenses doivent être cohérentes avec
cette transition
et donc c'est dans tous les domaines
qu'on va investir fortement mais
justement parlons de fiscalité car il va
bien falloir un moment financer cette
relance et ce budget européen est ce
qu'il va y avoir la création d'un impôt
européen
nous ce qu'on défend c'est qu'on peut
pas indéfiniment faire peser l'effort
sur les six contribuables entreprises ou
particuliers qui paient déjà beaucoup
d'impôts et qui vu la situation on va
pas les augmenter mais on voit bien
qu'on a pas on n'a pas de capacité à
augmenter les impôts c'est parce qu'on
cherche à faire c'est pas du tout notre
vision on voit en revanche que certains
ne paient pas assez d'impôts et je pense
aux cafards en termes de justice fiscale
on a quand même des gens qui vont
bénéficier de la relance qui vont
bénéficier de tout ce qu on va recréer
comme économie
est-ce qu'on peut les mettre un peu plus
à contribution c'est un objectif qu'on
poursuit et on fait des progrès au
niveau européen également
je vous ai parlé des importations la
taxe carbone aux frontières c'est une
bonne façon aussi de dire voilà nous on
a créé un espace économique de
prospérité vous nous apportez des
produits pourquoi pas maintenant il faut
qu'on puisse regarder si en terme de co2
on est cohérent donc voilà le type de
choses sur lesquelles on va pousser ce
qui est intéressant aujourd'hui c'est
que les lignes ont beaucoup bougé
moi je vois la situation il ya un an et
demi et aujourd'hui beaucoup de ces
débats là sont devenus débat maintenant
intéressant
la visite et de débat où chacun avait
surtout des les positions un peu de
principes
je crois qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde
comprend bien l'importance d'avancer
thierry breton commissaire européen au
marché intérieur propose lui un impôt
européen sur les grandes entreprises sur
0 2 % de leur chiffre d'affaires
en gros ça fait 10 milliards est-ce que
qu'est ce que le gouvernement pense tout
ça donc ça se discute il faut aussi qui
nous forme de cohérence parce que voyez
en france on a des efforts à faire on le
sait sur les impôts de production
relocaliser des activités en france
il faut que tout ça en arbitre on
regarde aussi ce qui est pertinent dans
chacun des pays
donc ce qui est sur la table aujourd'hui
c'est effectivement comment on finance
un vrai effort collectif et comment
surtout on met à contribution ceux qui
vont bénéficier la relance et qui
aujourd'hui n'y contribue pas assez et
moi j'ai surtout en ligne de mire je
vous dis les activités polluantes
les cafards et bien sûr les importations
de co2 donc sur cet impôt sur les
grandes entreprises vous n'avez pas trop
l'air d'accord je suis passé passé
magazine est d'accord ou pas il faut
qu'on comprenne comment ça s'organise
il faut qu'on comprenne voilà comment
aussi dans notre stratégie nationale ce
genre de choses peut fonctionner en
étant cohérent avec ce qu'on propose au
plan national
l'europe elle n'est pas là pour imposer
des choses elle est pas là pour
contraindre est là pour que ça
fonctionne mieux et donc il faut qu'on
comprenne comment ça peut s'organiser
donc la position de la france n'est pas
encore arrêté son exact pensent les
arbitrages lequel il faut qu'on
travaille mais nous on défend
fondamentalement l'idée qui nous faut
des ressources propres européennes et
qu'on peut pas indéfiniment demande à
des gens de paie des impôts si d'autres
à côté qui bénéficient de l'europe ne
partage pas en font une partie de ma de
ce que ça coûte sans fond de faire
marcher tout ça correctement alors on va
ouvrir la page politique de cet
entretien et parler des élections
municipales puisque nous sommes le
dernier jour pour déposer les listes des
candidats au second tour et d'ailleurs
il ya des alliances entre la république
en marche et les républicains qui sont
en train de fleurir dans certaines
villes on l'a vu à lyon ça s'est passé
également à bordeaux ce week-end c'est
une bonne nouvelle selon d'ailleurs je
tiens à dire à ce nombre de choses
d'aborder les municipales c'est d'abord
un projet ancré dans une réelle
tu es d'un territoire et donc il ya
effectivement des endroits où on a des
très bons projets défendus par des très
bons candidats qui parfois ne sont pas
en capacité d'aller au deuxième tour qui
cherche à voir comment leurs projets
leurs idées celles qui tombent bâti qui
les ont bâties avec eux voilà aussi les
forces du territoire les la société
civile peuvent être portés et donc
projet avec projets parfois des choses
qui se qui se rassemblent ensuite les
choses qui ne sont pas des alliances que
notre mouvement défend ce qui s'est
passé à lyon ce n'est celle de guérini a
été extrêmement clair ça ne correspond
pas à nos valeurs ça ne correspond pas
notamment au fait que par exemple une
vous la clarté sur l'engagement européen
s'il n'y a pas de clarté sur
l'engagement européen comment voulez
vous qu'on fasse des alliances donc je
pense que quand il ya des projets qui
peuvent se rassembler et les choses et
intéressante qui se font mais on n'est
pas dans une logique d'appareil n'y a
pas d'accord voyez entre christian jacob
et sa licence guérini on n'est pas en
train de faire des s'est passé pas de ça
qu'on parle on a des très bons projets
sur le terrain défendu par des par des
hommes et des femmes de conviction qu'on
bâtit une vision et on a vu pendant
cette crise les français ont bien vu que
leur mère était à la fois essentiel que
des relais de proximité qu'il y avait
des crises d'ailleurs ils étaient des
maillons fondamentaux de notre vie
collective et donc c'est sur ces projets
là que j'appelle d'abord les français à
voter et c'est comme ça que des
rapprochements éventuels peuvent se
faire question sur paris sébastien oui
sur paris donc agnès buzyn elle n'a pas
accepté l'accord avec d'accord avec
rachida dati est ce que vous le
regrettez moi je pense qu elle d'abord
un programme et un projet d'alternance
très fort elle est humaine et sincère et
porte une vraie vision et donc je lui
souhaite beaucoup de courage
je pense que là aussi on n'est pas dans
des logiques d'appareil on est dans le
vif de terrain justement vous parliez de
projets est ce que ces alliances entre
la république hors marché la droite pour
faire barrage aux écologistes elle
n'envoie pas un con tre message alors qu
emmanuel macron comme communique sur un
nouveau cap écologie n'est là aussi pas
d'idéologie du pragmatisme projet avec
projet et je laisse les femmes et les
hommes sur le terrain décidé alors je
parlais de ce nouveau cap d'emmanuel
macro on évoque dans la presse un
éventuel remaniement du gouvernement
pour sortir de cette crise sanitaire
amélie nonchalance que vous
personnellement vous sentez en danger
dans ce remaniement
bon moi je veux dire une chose on est
dans une période où beaucoup de gens
font dire beaucoup de choses au
président qui ne l'a pas dit
et c'est très grave donc je vais pas me
livrer devant vous
à des commentaires sur ce que j'appelle
des cabales de caniveau vous faites
référence au journal du dimanche qui
évoquait vos critiques sur le mois
téléphone jean marc schoen la république
je ne ferai aucun commentaire parce que
il ya des mensonges d'apprentis
flingueurs qui ne mérite pas de
commentaire le président à sa parole et
lui faire des choses qu'il n'a pas dites
c'est très grave
moi je suis pas là envoyé dans
l'engagement qui est le mien pour servir
le projet du président pour faire ce
genre de commentaires et ce qu'ils font
je penserai bien réfléchir parce que je
suis pas sûr qu'ils servent les français
et je pensais pas ça qu'on attend d'eux
donc oui je pense que je m'en tiendrai
là et ça monsieur ça me paraît
suffisamment clair l'engagement qui est
le nôtre c'est servir les français
servait le président et l'engagement
qu'il a pris et donc ce n'est pas de se
livrer à ces racontars vous souhaitez
rester au gouvernement
c'était un honneur d'être au
gouvernement c'est un honneur de se
battre pour l'europe c'est un honneur de
pouvoir porter avec conviction un projet
qui est humaniste qui est réformiste qui
fait que voilà on a bien de parler de
l'europe
c'est à cette maille là que la france
sera forte et donc évidemment c'est
d'abord le premier ministre et le
président qui octroie leur confiance et
je le vis comme un honneur de chaque
instant très bien le message est clair
le message est passé merci beaucoup
amélie de montchanin d'avoir été notre
invité politique dans bonjour chez vous
merci beaucoup sébastien cours attend
d'avoir mené à cette interview avec moi